- On this episode we talk
location, location, location,
how I celebrate victories,
and what to get your mama.
You ask questions and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
- [DRock] And action.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode
93 of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Really excited, only seven
episodes away from episode 100.
We just had a morning meeting,
I think we've decided,
yes, we decided that we're
gonna tape it on, tape it.
We're gonna record it on Monday the 18th,
help me here, Monday the 18th,
in New York City, at 4:30.
We've created a Facebook RSVP invite
that is linked below.
In the Facebook post,
let's make sure we do that,
and in the YouTube, and I will tweet it.
We want you here, in New York City.
This is the time to cash in on your miles.
This is the time to throw
three of your homies
into a car and do a roadtrip.
This is the time to get to New York City,
meet up with other
Vayniacs during the day.
You guys do your thing.
You're big boys and girls.
But at 3:00 pm, either
in a park, like we did
on episode, what was it?
Do we know?
If we don't know, here is it.
(snaps)
All right, got some dudes
together for today's show,
so somebody just jump right in,
let's get right into it.
- Sure.
- Your name?
- Kyle Cummings.
- Kyle.
Say hello to the VaynerNation.
- Hi everybody.
- And if it's raining or something crazy,
we'll do it here at Vayner,
and so, VaynerNation,
I would love to see you
in New York City, March 18th,
4:30, episode 100.
We'll line up everybody
and we will just roll.
We will Q&A our asses off on
#AskGaryVee episode one hundo.
Should we do?
Yeah, let's do it now.
Here we go.
These are the names, 14 names.
Give me your hat, Staphon.
A little Warrior's hat.
These are the 14 people
that correctly guessed
what their favorite football team,
the person they would draft.
I'm gonna pull one name.
You will then email India.
Love it.
India, what's your email address?
- ikieser, K-I-E-S-E-R, @vaynermedia.com.
- Great, you will email
India if you're the winner.
No weird stalker people hitting up India
to like, "Do this! Pick my question!"
Don't stalk her, you'll
be eliminated permanently
from the #AskGaryVee Show.
So the winner gets a jersey,
and I don't know if rookie numbers.
I bought a lot of rookie
number jersies in my career.
I would recommend everybody here
have us buy it for you in late August
once that number is firm.
Rookies tend to change their numbers
and campus players get cut, and you don't
want to be rolling around like I am
with a lot of Jet players with the number
that doesn't match what
their actual number is.
And the winner of the contest
for the jersey from me to
you from your favorite team
based on the NFL draft is...
Oh, by the way, this person,
heartbreaker for you.
This person, you were almost the person,
but it slipped and then this person won.
So bad news for Blake Jameson,
which is tough, because I know Blake.
Good dude, sorry.
Bad news sucks, right?
And the winner is...
Anthony DeNardis!
Let's clap it up, guys.
Big ups, Anthony, email India, congrats.
Oh, here it is, from YouTube,
Anthony, big winner, congrats.
I like these contests.
I think more contests are in our future.
India!
Let's get into the show.
- Yay.
- [Voiceover] @BottledGrapes asks,
"We have a brick and mortar shop.
"In today's technology
world, how important
"is location, location, location?"
- Location, location, location.
So I think the 1998 version of me
would have said, "Oh, it
doesn't matter as much anymore,
"in 20 years, 10 years,
it'll be all e-com."
As the gray hairs have come in,
I recognize things take longer to evolve.
I would say location matters
tremendously still today,
and very much over the next 10 years.
Do I think 20 years from
today that we will be
in a 30, 40, 50, 60, 70% e-com world
and things will be overpriced by location
in a physical world?
I do.
But I would say for the next half decade
to a full decade, location is
still enormously important.
People still go to stores,
people still drive their cars,
people still are in dense
areas where a great location
really matters, and so
I would highly recommend
respecting the bricks
and mortars location.
Now, that being said,
there's a more interesting
variation of this answer, which is
today's technology world,
are you able to just rely on
bricks and mortars location,
location, location,
and that is a big fat no.
If you were not thinking about your e-com,
your mobile strategy, your app culture,
your content strategy,
your social strategy,
your digital strategy,
you are just basically
just setting the game plan in motion
to the demise of your business,
and so location still matters,
but the investment into the future,
especially with the acceleration
and the exponential growth
of our culture around digital behavior
is an enormous mistake.
So you need both.
That I highly believe in.
Who needs that room?
What?
I do?
That's fine, I'm finishing my show.
Alright, go ahead.
- [Voiceover] Anthony asks,
"Is standing your ground
"during negotiations something that is in
"someone's DNA, or can it be taught?"
- Anthony, I think it is probably
a very strong combination of both.
I, for a long time, up
until July 7th, 2014,
believed that almost everything was DNA.
But something that does
not come natural to me
is taking care of my health, right?
And what I've done is I've hacked,
and I've taught myself, and
now is it my own behavior?
No, I have a babysitter.
His name's Mike.
You've seen him, you've heard of him.
So I do think certain things can be taught
to a degree, meaning, for example,
I've been playing basketball more often
and my jump shot is getting better.
I've brought back my running jumper.
Staphon knows what I'm talking about.
And so I do think negotiating skills
is something that can be taught,
but it would be naive to not recognize
that some people are just
born with that talent.
So probably, like every
answer to every question
in the world, the answer is both.
A little bit of training and building up,
I think I taught AJ to
be a better negotiator.
I think he naturally had it in him,
but I think there was some
teaching moments there
at the garage sales of New Jersey, and so
I actually think the way it can be taught
is more through osmosis.
I think surrounding yourself
with those kind of strong negotiators
is better than watching a video about it
or reading about how to do it,
and so I think learned
behavior by feeling it,
not just by reading it, is the way to go.
So I would say both.
I would say 80 20.
I think 80% of the equation is natural,
but I do think you can be taught 20% lift
off of where your natural place
in the lexicon of negotiation,
or maybe anything else, really is.
- [Voiceover] Dmitry asks, "How
do you celebrate victories?"
- Dmitry, I took this question
for a very specific reason,
because this is absolutely, no question,
one of the flaws of my being.
I am terrible at celebrating victories.
It is actually quite sad in some ways
if you decide to look at it that way,
or a very strong winner's mentatlity
which is how I like to look at it,
but the truth is I stink at it.
As a matter of fact,
one of the bigger flaws
that I think I'm creating
at VaynerMedia as a culture
is that we don't celebrate our wins.
We land big new accounts.
We grow like crazy.
We win awards.
Hush, hush.
Nothing.
No chest pounding, and I
think it's interesting,
because when you look at me as a character
and you look how I roll,
for all the humble bragging
and the outright bragging, and the ego
and the confidence that I spew out there,
it's funny.
It's always in hindsight,
and it's in showmanship,
it's not in reality, meaning,
I celebrate victories poorly.
For example, the New York
Rangers and the New York Yankees
have both won championships for me.
They won their championship.
I was very happy for
about a couple of hours.
No parades, no next day taking
off and like soaking it in.
I won, and I moved on,
and I stopped caring.
I'm gonna say it here first.
I've really never said this
out loud outside of my family.
I am completely convinced
that if the New York Jets
win a Super Bowl before I buy them,
that I will no longer
like the Jets that much
and all my energy will
then be transplanted
100,000% into the
New York Knicks.
I firmly believe that.
I just completely believe that.
I love the climb.
I celebrate victories in a very soft,
non appropriate way.
I'm really dissapointed
in the way that I celebrate victories.
It's something that I want to work on
because smelling the
roses is an important part
of growing and living, and it's just
not something I'm good at.
- [Voiceover] Corey asks,
"What should I get my
mom for Mother's Day?"
- Corey, I think the big
strategy for Mother's Day 2015
is for people that are
watching the show to recognize
a lot of their moms are on Pinterest,
and that they should go to
their mom's Pinterest board
and see what mama has been pinning
and buy her something from there,
and so if you're not
lucky enough to have that,
where your mama is pinning,
then I would highly recommend
looking at her social media and looking at
what she's tweeting or Facebooking,
which will not be as good as Pinterest,
but you might find the
diamond in the rough,
and then, if you can't do that,
the move that so many don't do
that I highly recommend for
you and the VaynerNation,
is to randomly call
your mom's best friend,
the one that you might have
not talked to in a long time,
or it might be your aunt that
you only talk to once a year
to wish a happy birthday
or whoever it may be,
and ask her what, or him,
what you should buy your mom,
because friends know, and I
think that would be thoughtful.
I think putting in the effort
to try to really buy your mom
something she wants for
Mother's Day is the move.
I feel like I've inspired
three or four of you,
because that's about as high
as I think this will go,
but that makes me happy,
because three to four of your moms
are gonna have a better Mother's Day
because of the #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Voiceover] Dr. Julie
asks, "As VaynerMedia
"continues to grow, what is the one thing
"the company has done to
keep the culture hungry?"
- Doc, everything stems from the top.
My hunger level is so
intense it's crippling,
and so, because of that, the
culture continues to be hungry
because I will suffocate the culture
to allow nothing else to creep in.
No complacency, no
celebrating the victories
allows you to stay really damn hungry.
We've haven't accomplished shit yet,
and so, yeah, we're the fastest growing
social digital agency ever, and yeah,
we're unstoppable, and
we're great and all this,
but we haven't done anything
that I'd like to accomplish yet,
which is, I don't know, to
win the whole goddamn game.
To make every single client,
every single employee,
every single agency in the game
recognize we are the best
and it's disrespectful
to even allow yourself to think
that you can compete with us
and so you should really
focus on being number two.
Does that answer your question?
All right.
Good show.
I like that, that was tight.
That was tight.
Yesterday was thoughtful.
Today was tight.
Question of the day.
How do you celebrate victories?
As I'm trying to work on myself
to make myself better, maybe your comments
will help me and give me some ideas.
Don't come up with bull crap.
Don't say, "Oh, I go on vacations
"or buy myself something nice,"
just to give me advice, I
need you to tell me the truth.
What do you do to celebrate victories?
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Monday the 18th.
Get your ass to New York.
I don't want to see people tweeting
today and tomorrow and be like,
"Oh, I'm definitely gonna come,"
and then when I look you didn't make it.
If you want to be here, you'll be here.
Figure it out.
You can walk.
(all chuckling)
- [India] Bottled Grapes, we have
a brick and mortar shop.
In today's technology world, how important
is location, location, location?
- She can't say location.
- [India] I did that on purpose!
- I know.
I know.
(overlapping chatter)
- [Voiceover] Look at the rabbit.
- [India] Does it have a name?
- [Gary] Rabbit freaks me out.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] I'm super into it.
(all laughing)
- [India] I thought I was dark.
- [Steve] You're rubbing off on Gary.
- You're wearing all black, India.
- [India] It's true.